Thanks.
Thanks very much.
And thanks for inviting me.
I should say I'm no longer the chief has
story and although I still do some work
with the Foreign Office,
but that is a bit relevant.
So I'm just going to say a little bit
about where I'm coming from on this before
I talk about the subject of the book.
Um,
the Foreign Office these days is the only
major department to state that employs
a Kadra professional historians within it.
And other departments used to have them,
but they didn't have them anymore,
which some of it I'm so sorry about.
And the historians have two main roles.
One is to publish a series of books,
which are the official history
of British foreign policy,
but the other is something called
historical advice to ministers and senior
officials. Now that can be absolutely
anything. It can be a very small thing.
Like I'm in this to wanting a
joke for a speech. Not very often.
They're not usually very funny.
Um,
or else they think they can make their
own jokes, which is very dangerous,
but it can be major pieces of research.
And really the the principal role of
the historian says that when there is a
current policy issue that has some kind
of historical controversy behind it and
there are an awful lot of
those as you would appreciate.
That's when the historians come in.
Now,
I joined the phone office at very,
very,
very long time ago and even when I
joined there's an obvious letter was all
ready.
One of those things that kept coming back
and kept coming back and because it's
one of those things that a
lot of people have heard of,
but very few people know what it is.
I'm going to just say a little bit about
it in a moment to just finish my own
social did a bio graphical bit while
I was working as chief historian,
I got more and more drawn
into intelligence history
and that's not really what I
special that was in various aspects of it.
So obviously isn't over yet is an
intelligence story though these days it's
better known as what they call a
classic case of disinformation,
which is something that I hope it's of
interest to all of you here in the sorts
of business who are in. So, um, let me
say a little bit about the lecture itself.
Now,
this document was the letter supposedly
written by a man called [inaudible] who
was the head of the Bolshevik propaganda
organization in Soviet Russia after the
revolution in 1917.
Uh,
and it was written to the
British Communist Party,
basically telling them to up their
game a bit in kind of agitation, uh,
and to lobby on behalf of a
treaty which had been negotiated,
which would mean a for Soviet Union.
We don't need to go into
too much detail here,
but the point about this latter is it
normally if it was always sending letters
to communist parties all over the world,
um,
exhorting them to greater
revolutionary fervor.
I said there's nothing particularly
special about the APP. What makes it,
this is an you have letter of
special is when it arrived,
which is in 1924 or nine,
1924 saw the first ever Labour government
in London took office in January,
1924. Uh, one of the first things it
did was to recognize the Soviet Union.
There you are as opposed
to de facto said it was a,
it was a big deal for the Soviet Union
to have official recognition and then the
government among other things was involved
in negotiating these treaties with
Russia,
which by the summer of 1924 had been
signed in draft but had not yet gone
through parliament.
Now the,
the traditional ruling parties
or Britain at the time,
the Conservatives and the
liberals on the other side,
they both thought it would be a good
idea to let labor take office for a while
and basically bugger things up.
Perhaps I shouldn't say that on Youtube.
I'm sure I can. Um, so that they could
show that they were unfit to Gavin.
Actually, they done far
better than anybody expected.
And by the summer of 1920 fourth,
both the other parties were getting
a bit restive and everything.
It was about time to get rid of
them and there was a scandal, uh,
which involved a threat to prosecutor,
a certain writer,
and then they withdrew it.
I mean,
we won't go into all of that
when we can talk about stuff.
It was essentially during the summer
of 1924 the evidence suggest that the
Russians were not sending inflammatory
letters because they didn't want the
Labor government to fall.
However,
the Labor government
did resign in October,
the beginning of October, 1924 over a
vote, losing a vote of no confidence.
So you're going to have
a general election.
It's at this point that
the letter arrives.
Now I should point out that one of the
disinformation factors in this whole
story is that nobody has ever seen
what you might call an original of this
document.
There's no letter in any paper for the
only text we really have is a text that
was sent in a telegram from the Secret
Intelligence Services Station in Riga in
Latvia to secret intelligence
headquarters in London at the beginning of
October,
1924 and although a lot of
people afterwards claiming
to have alternative texts,
the evidence all indicates that they are
all read translations of that original
telegram. Uh, as, as a complicated story,
we don't need to have all the details,
but the point is when it arrived,
the government resigns and that
the, uh, the wraps and Mcdonald,
the prime minister asked the king to
dissolve parliament and corn elections who
called an election on the 8th of October,
1924 on the 9th of October.
This telegram comes in to the
secret intelligence service,
which is what book you now
might think of as they're,
my sex was called at that time. And my
sex is the second world war termination.
But it's sis is what it was in
the usual way of these things.
Any kind of report that it was taught,
it was taught entailed.
It was the,
the things that could identify it as an
intelligence report where it moved from
it and then it was circulated to the
Foreign Office and to certain other white
taught apartments.
At the same time rumors began circulating
in London that there was some kind of
inflammatory document around,
nobody quite knew what it was.
Certain people started claiming there.
Got It even though they didn't have it,
but essentially it one way or another
it was leaked to the press a bit to the
right wing press in particularly
and to conservative central office.
So that during the
general election campaign,
the whole letter,
uh,
became a big labor bashing instrument.
And the reason for that was that the right
wing interest claimed that the letter
showed clearly that Labour was in thrall
to the reds in Moscow and that they
could not be trusted.
And therefore, uh, now,
so all through the campaign,
there are rumors about this letter and
it was eventually published by the Daily
Mail. Who else one might
say on the 25th of October,
the election was taking place on the 29th.
Now,
there are all sorts of
complicating factors in this.
One of which is the official
response to the letter. As I said,
it's an obvious, I've sent lots
of documents like this and that.
First nobody seemed to pay
too much attention to it.
They didn't think it was
different to anything else,
but then they started to worry about it
in the foreign office because partly of
there being a general election campaign
and because they felt it was so
outrageous,
there had to be some kind of official
response because if the letter where to
believed and spread around and it looked
as if they hadn't done anything about
it,
that would look reflect badly.
So our response was drafted in
the Foreign Office and the draft,
sorry, follow me on this cause
this, this bit of it is important.
That slightly obscure the draft note of
protest from Britain to Soviet Russia
was sent from the
Foreign Office two ramps.
We Mcdonald who was both foreign secretary
and prime minister at this point.
He's in Wales campaigning
for the general election.
So he's not in London. He's actually
by himself. It's not like it is today.
He was on his own with just a typist, no
advisors, no secretaries know nothing.
He gets the draft,
he amends it quite extensively and he
sends it back to the Foreign Office.
At this point,
the permanent under secretary,
which is the top official
in the Foreign Office,
decides that the amended version must
be what Mcdonald really wants to send,
and he gives that version to the press
and he also gives the text of it does not
have left it to the press so that they
are both published on that fateful 25th
of October.
Now,
McDonald claimed that he had lots of tall
intended that his amended draft should
be sent out and published.
He wanted it to come back again so
that he could sign off on the revision.
This has never been satisfactory because
later on there are some documents
missing from the file.
Good old stories and mystery stories says
that it's impossible to be absolutely
sure,
but whatever happened,
it's not actually the content of this
document. It's what was done with it,
which makes it important
and which qualifies it as a
a disinformation document.
Now the difficulty is you can say,
okay, is this information, but by whom,
against whom and for what purpose is
much more difficult gauge because it very
soon began to be suspected that this
document was not actually from synovium at
all, that it had been forged.
Some people said Labor,
the believer party
having lost the election,
although this didn't lose the election
for them, that they lost the election.
They then accused the,
when everybody really the
Conservative Party civil service,
the intelligence services, everybody
they regarded as the establishment,
they accused them of concocting this
document in order to damage Labor's
prospects in the campaign then,
but the question is who did actually
forge it and we still absolute,
you don't have a definitive answer there.
There are lots of possible candidates,
indeed it could conceivably have
been concocted in this country.
That is less likely I think, but there
are very many different constituencies,
all of whom had an interest in causing
trouble in the British political
establishment or indeed
causing trouble in Moscow.
Because it is possible that even if so,
Navea didn't write it,
it might've been forged, um, as part of a,
at in trouble Shimik power
struggle because at this
point we knew that starling
was trying to discredits and
IVF who was one of his rivals.
And so there's a possibility that it
was actually done to disrupt Bolshevik
politics.
It may have been forged by what
we call white Russian interests.
That is the people who were against
the Bolsheviks, but who were Russians,
a lot of whom were in exile and
in Germany or in France, uh,
and in the Baltic states,
busily intriguing and trying to get
rid of the Bolshevik regime in Russia.
And then of course,
you've got the whole convoluted
state of British politics as well.
So everybody was accusing everybody else
without ever being able to quite get to
the bottom of it.
But it became known as a
political dirty tricks, uh,
example that was raised in
successive elections time after time.
In fact,
there isn't a decade since the light to
twenties when there's an Avia of letter
has not been raised in the media or in
politics or in the course of an election
in 2017 during the election campaign
in 2017 you may remember there were all
kinds of things in the press about how
some remarks made by European Commission
officials might've been deliberately
placed in water to interfere with the
electoral process. I mean, you know, uh,
it was just like there's
an Avia have led to this.
It's one of those things
that people bring up.
The real truth of it is very difficult
to ascertain because you know,
it is a very long time ago now. I came
into this story. Well, it, as I said,
when I joined the Foreign Office,
it was already one of those countries,
cities that never quite went to bed.
But then in the 1990s when
the Labor government came in,
when the Blair government came in,
uh, it came up again with a vengeance.
And in 1998 a book was published.
This book was written by Nigel West,
which is the pen name of a,
a former Tory MP,
Rupert Talison and a former
KGB colonel called Alexander.
Off this book was called the crown jewels.
And the crown jewels was the codename
for information given to the Russians by
the so called Cambridge spies,
you know,
Philby Burgess and Clayton
and lunch and so on.
And this book purported to have all sorts
of stories about British history based
on that information that was
held in Russia having been
transmitted by traitors.
There was a chapter in this book
on the [inaudible] of letter,
which said it had definitely been
written by a man called per Croskey,
Yvan Procroft Ski, who was
a former Cyrus officer. Uh,
the, the book caused quite
a stir in this country.
There were questions in parliament on
the lines of why do we have to read about
our history on the basis of what traitors
have given to Russia and the Foreign
Secretary who was then Robin Cook.
At first,
he was absolutely astonished that anybody
could get exercised about something
that had happened in 1924 but then you
soon realized that in the Labour party
there's an obvious letter was still
very much a sore point and a hot issue.
And so he ordered an investigation.
Now the complicating factor of course is
that the real evidence on all this lies
in the archives of the UKS
intelligence agencies. Um,
and in particularly in sis archives
which are not open to the public.
And this is how I came into it because
he stood up in the House of Commons over
my,
there have been a number of occasions
when a minister has stood up in parliament
and said, I have ordered
investigation from my historians.
They never tell you this beforehand.
You just find out afterwards,
however he said precisely this.
And so my role was,
cause I have privileged
access to these archives,
was to go in and to try
and find out the truth.
He still didn't really believe that
anybody could be terribly exercise to pass
something that happened so long ago.
But he was sitting disabused of that.
And when the official report at the end
of my investigation was published in
1999,
there were lots of messages that came in
to the Foreign Office saying that their
relations or somebody had been
involved in it all. They all wasn't it.
There was one particular guy who was
a very, uh, if you do read this book,
there's a very strange guy called Donald
in Thorne who despite his name was
actually British conservative.
Uh,
his son got in touch with me after the
report was published to say my father
wouldn't never have been
involved in anything like this.
His grandson who was living in Italy
at the time sent me a fax saying,
I always knew my grandfather
was involved in this. So,
so even Robin Kolbe was convinced that
you can't quite put this knob here of
data to bed. Now we didn't manage to
get to the bottom. Everything could.
I did go to Moscow as part of this
investigation, which was very interesting.
This was actually in the fairly brief
ish period between the end of the Cold
War.
And when things didn't go quite so well
when actually relations with Russia were
pretty good. Uh, they cooperated in, in
our investigations and they were very,
uh, very helpful to me. And so, you know,
it was all absolutely fine at the time
because they have an interest too.
And you are often, you
know, ever since I did this,
I keep an alert on my name on Google,
on hold. You'll be glad to know part,
not just to be being Darrious I showed
you because you get particularly ration
websites saying,
Jill Bennett has said x or y.
I mean, I never have, and there's
nothing I can do about it,
but I like to know that somebody said it,
if you see what I mean,
because you never know when you're
going to be ambushed. It's part,
it's just kind of the fixture. And it's
partly to do with this particular story,
which remains inflammatory
nearly a hundred years later.
There has,
there were definite accusations that
the British intelligence community were
involved in this whole thing.
And that indeed they concocted the letter.
I think the idea of them concocting
their letter is unlikely.
I think it's entirely possible
that some members of the sis,
including a man called Desmond Morton,
whom I also wrote a book about who
was a very, very secret squirrel, um,
that he knew this letter was forged a
and he and certain other people in the
told you this community what absolutely
have no time for the Labour party smooth
just on its way into the public domain,
shall we say.
And we're not displeased at
the way it was used, but it is,
it is certainly a case
of just information.
It was smearing the Labour party in a
way that was unfair because actually they
were absolutely not in thrall.
They were very anticommunist. Uh,
they will not in thrall to Moscow,
but of course, even in the 1920s,
and this is actually one
of the contemporary lessons
of this episode today.
Everybody talks now about disinformation,
fake news, whatever you want to call it,
going around the world in seconds
because of the Internet and digital
communications generally.
Of course that's true.
But even in the 1920s as story could get
around pretty damn quickly and it only
had to be mentioned in the press and
it had legs and those legs could run an
offer on way.
So it's not,
there's no kind of enormous change it and
how you might deal with disinformation
is not that different.
Um,
the kind of techniques that were developed
at the time to try and how do you
counter this?
How do you look at stories which you
think might be false and the techniques
that are used in the
intelligence services. First
of all, you look at the source,
what do you think the source was, but also
you tried to look at intent, you know,
in the military parlance capability
plus intent equals threat.
If you,
you know,
look at where your think the story
is coming from and what interest,
whoever it is you think it might be,
might have.
And that does help a to try and identify
this information and be to try and
think how you might be able to respond
to it. And actually they perhaps didn't,
we certainly didn't use
those terms in the 1920s,
but there were people who were
trying to do that. Then, um,
I just want to mention one,
particularly a tricky character and all
the story who illustrates the kind of
problems that they were faced. There
is a man called Vladimir all off. Now,
all of how the distinction of having
worked in the Cyrus to see police in the
Bolshevik secret police and then for
white trashing organizations in exile,
he set up a forgery bureau in Berlin in
the 1920s he was given accomodation and
facilities by German intelligence.
He was paid money by French intelligence,
by SIS,
by Red Russians,
and by white trash bins.
And he and his colleagues
manufactured documents to order.
It doesn't mean they were all
absolutely false, but they were expert.
And so trying to find out whether a
document like there's an Avia of letter
really was true. It was almost
impossible because after all,
you know, Bolshevik Rachios is routed
in, in a, it's my secret state.
They're not going to tell you much about
it and it's an Avia abs own reaction to
it was why I didn't
actually write that one,
but then somebody put it in front of me,
I would have signed it.
It was not terribly reassuring.
Wedding Orloff characters like all
off and he was not the only one.
Make the whole story pretty tricky and
make it difficult to really get to the
bottom of this and all through
the decades it comes up,
as I said in general elections,
it came up during a Labour government,
Harold Wilson's two governments when
of course Harold Wilson already rather
paranoid about the activities
of the intelligence agencies.
You know in the background of
labor is Nothi of letter is,
it's very much something
to come to you with.
As I was just saying to one of you
beforehand, Jack Straw, foreign secretary,
former foreign secretary with whom I
work quite closely when he was there,
he says it's an OBF letter
is mother's milk to him.
His father who had been a plumber and who
was a labor activist and a trade union
is his father had taught him about the
an you have letter when he was a little
boy,
as a classic example of the kind of
things that the establishment does to do
labor down. Well, you know, he's not
the only one who takes that view.
Another factor, the fact, I'll
stop for a moment for questions,
but another person I need to bring
you to this story is Kim Philby,
who I'm sure you all know about it.
Of course he's one of the Cambridge spies,
but there was a major investigation across
my tall investigation in the 60s that
was done, um, as a direct result
of the defection of Philby. Now,
Philby of course, had been suspected
in the 50s and indeed left eye size,
but he'd been exonerated.
He bluffed it out.
Essentially they couldn't get the
evidence and sis kept on defending him and
saying they were sure
he was not a traitor.
So that when he did
actually defect in 1963,
it was an enormous shock and normal
shop to the whole of the intelligence
establishment. And they got together the
different agencies and they said, look,
if this can have happened and we
didn't know what else might there be.
So they formed a committee to try and go
back through the history of operations
of the intelligence services,
to look at other cases where there
might've been disinformation,
uh, you know, something trip
treachery that they have not detected.
And one of the cases they looked at
was this is an awfully of letter.
And they commissioned a formidable
lady called Millicent Baggott,
who just retired from her,
my five to run this, uh,
inter into departmental
organization and inquiry.
And she did very much what Jairus
to do. 30 years later, she went,
looked in all the intelligence
archives and so on.
But of course in the 1960
is you couldn't admit that,
am I six or am I five or
GCHQ actually existed.
They were not yet on the legislative 14.
They hadn't been allowed.
You weren't allowed to talk about,
you weren't allowed to release a document
that referred to any of the agencies
by name or that indeed
referred to their activities.
So everything that she did was under
wraps and indeed her report has never been
published.
Although I was lucky enough to be able to
draw on it extensively when I came out.
Now the camp I do mine, um, investigation,
of course the whole legislative framework
has changed and all the agencies were
on a legislative 14.
You were allowed to
know that they existed.
You are allowed even
to mention their heads.
And so it was much easier to then be
able to talk about in our report to talk
about what sis or am I five and really
have been doing in the years beforehand.
Now it's still hasn't gotten away.
Um,
I was asked if I would like to write a
book about this because it kept coming
back. I mean, we didn't put it to bed
in 1999. It comes up again and again.
It came up in the referendum campaign.
Um, when there was a, an article,
for example,
criticizing the way that the daily mail
were laying into David Cameron during
the, um, during the referendum,
the referendum campaign
because of him, you know,
obviously, um, campaigning that
perhaps not very hard for remaining.
This is just like what they did to
Ramsey Mcdonald's over this offering of
letters said it comes back when I actually
started looking for mentions of it,
I found they were, they
were everywhere. Um,
and so it is literally the
conspiracy that never dies.
And although I've moved,
I hope the debate on a bit in that,
in the end,
I do think that Perkowski who
was fingered in the 1998 book,
it's certainly a very credible candidate,
but who asked him to do it,
I don't know.
And there are still any
number of candidates,
which means that although I've been able
to bring a lot more stuff out into the
open,
it's not dead yet.
And the message of the book really
is that good conspiracies never die.
How going to stop there
and take questions. Okay.